better come back all right  i'll try but if i don't nope not having  that conversation  you know we thought you were dead nobody  heard from you  it's a bridge through time nobody's been  foolish enough to actually try it  i'm not giving up on my friend katie  we're talking about  time collapsing in on itself eventually  tear reality apart  ooh okay uh i have so many questions  um but i like the energy so let's just  turn this thing on before i ever think  did you not just hear me say tearing  reality apart  we're gonna go get clint out of the  wrong timeline cut monica off from her  future self  simple i like it that's still messing  with time that's that that might work  you have one shot at this  great let's go get hawkeye  [Music]  you don't understand i agreed to this  [Music]  what  [Music]  is  [Music]  you